les volants et les raquettes étaient de
sortie au gymnase de la malle me donne à
maurepas un tournoi de simple hommes et
dames était organisé par le club local
ce samedi 30 novembre
un rendez vous qui a réuni des badistes
venus de toute la france on parle de du
niveau le plus bas possible qu'ils aient
le p12 nc jusqu'à aire 4h05 qui a déjà
un très bon niveau régional on s'est
plus haut niveau régional
ensuite nous n'avons pas ouvert cette
année au niveau national en terme de
classement doit dire n3 n2 n1 objectif
de cette journée pour les 120
participants présents répéter ses gammes
en vue des plus grosses échéances
prévues cette saison
le but est d' ajuster ses coûts au
millimètre donc de mobilité dans le
premier match et là c'était plus acheter
assez mobile mais j'étais sur le volant
et je faisais des fautes à mon niveau
c'est surtout pas faire de faute
les gestes simples en fait ne pas les
rater c'est surtout ça à notre niveau et
puis on a le match était et est bien
parti donc j'ai pu tester des coûts un
peu plus difficile mais surtout pas
faire d'erreur pour se perfectionner les
joueurs disputent cinq à six parties au
maximum des matches de poules et des
matchs éliminatoires
tous les participants mettent en place
une stratégie personnelle pour aborder
ce tournoi chaque joueur va voir sa
propre stratégie entre guillemets il y
en a qui vont rentrer tête baissée dans
le tournoi dès le premier point et est
frappé fort et pour montrer qu'ils sont
présents et devons prendre le temps de
monter en puissance au fur à mesure que
que le tournoi avance on reste encore au
niveau amateur on n'est pas des
professionnels du badminton loin de là
mais qu'on prenne plaisir à jouer
si vous avez manqué ce tournoi deuxième
rendez-vous sera organisé par le club
les 18 et 19 avril prochains
cette fois ci les joueurs s'affronteront
en double les inscriptions s'ouvriront
dans les prochains jours